the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi today's lesson well I settled for the
title circular functions but I guess it
could have been called a lot of
different things it could have been
called trigonometry without triangles it
could have been called trigonometry
revisited and the whole point is that
much of what today's lecture hinges on
is a hang-up that bothered me and which
I think may bother you and is worth
while discussing I remember when I was
in high school I asked my trigonometry
teacher why would I have to know
trigonometry and his answer was
surveyors use it and at that particular
time I didn't know what I was going to
be but I knew what I wasn't going to be
I wasn't going to be a surveyor and I
kind of took the course kind of lightly
and really got clobbered a year or two
later when I got into calculus and
physics courses so what I would like to
do today is to introduce the notion of
what we call circular functions and
point out what the connection is between
these and the trigonometric functions
that we learned when we studied the
subject that we call trigonometry and
which might better have been called
numerical geometry let me get to the
point right away let's imagine that I
say circular functions to you I think
it's rather natural that as soon as I
say that if you think of a circle and
because you think of a circle let me
draw a circle here and let me assume
that the radius of this circle is one in
other words I have the circle here x
squared plus y squared equals one now
the thing is this when I talk about and
I'm assuming now that you are familiar
with the trigonometric functions in the
traditional sense and in fact the first
section of our supplementary notes in
the reading material that goes with the
present lecture takes care of the fact
that if you don't recall some of these
things - well there's ample opportunity
for refreshing your minds and getting
some review in here but the idea is
something like this when we're talking
about calculus we talk about functions
of a real variable we are assuming that
our functions have the property that the
domain is a set of suitably chosen real
numbers
the image is a suitably chosen set of
real numbers we do not think of inputs
as being angles and things of this type
and so the question is how can we define
for example let's call it the sign
machine let me come down here I'll call
it the sign machine if the input is the
number T I want the output say to be
sine T but you see now I'm talking about
a number not an angle well one way of
doing this thing visually is the old
idea of the number line let us think of
a number as being a length the same as
we do in coordinate geometry okay we
mark off lengths along the x axis and
the y axis
let me think of T as being a length as
such I can take T and lay it off along
my circle in such a way that the length
originates at s and terminates shall we
say at some point P whose coordinates
are x and y now notice what I'm saying
here I lay the length off along the
circumference I'll talk more about that
a little bit later
no so far so good no mention of the
would angle here or anything like this
now wherever T terminates and again
conventions here if T is positive I lay
it off along the circle in the so-called
positive direction namely what
counterclockwise if T is negative I'll
lay it off in the cut in the clockwise
direction etc the usual trigonometric
conventions now what I do is is at the
point P I drop a perpendicular okay and
I define the sine of T to be the length
PR and the cosine of P to be the length
so R in other words I could write that
like this I could write down that I'm
defining sine T to be the length of RP
in that direction meaning of course that
this is just a fancy way of saying that
the sine of T will just be the
y-coordinate of the point at which the
length t terminates on the circle and in
a similar way
cosine T will be the directed length
from o to R or more conventionally the
x-coordinate now notice I can do this
with any length whatever length I'm
given I just mark this length off it's a
finite length eventually it has to
terminate someplace on the circle
wherever it terminates the x-coordinate
of the point of termination is called
the cosine of T and the y-coordinate is
called the sine of T and notice that in
this way both the sine and the cosine
are functions which map real numbers
into real numbers is that part I hope is
clear right
notice again I can mimic the usual
traditional trigonometry I can define
the tangent of T to be the number sine T
divided by the number cosine T etc and
I'll leave those details to the reading
material
I can ascertain rather interesting
results the same way as I could in
regular traditional trigonometry in fact
I can get some certain results very
nicely I remember for example well I
don't even want this but how did you
talk about the sine of 0 when one talked
about traditional trigonometry how did
you embed a zero degree angle into a
triangle and things of this type notice
that in terms of my tradition here that
well and we'll summarize these results
in a minute but notice for example that
the sine of zero comes out to be zero
very nicely because when T is zero the
length zero terminates at s s is on the
x axis that makes what y equal to zero
notice also that if the radius of my
circle is 1 the circumference is 2 pi so
for example what I usually think of a 90
degree angle would be the length PI over
2 and without making any fuss over this
again leaving most of the details to the
reading and to the simplicity of just
plugging these things in we arrive at
these rather familiar results we also
get very quickly
in addition to these results things like
the fundamental result that we always
like with trigonometric functions that
sine squared T plus cosine squared T is
one and how do we know that remember
that cosine T was just another name for
the x-coordinate at which the point
terminated on the circle in other words
notice that cosine squared T is x
squared sine squared T is y squared the
x-coordinate and the y-coordinate are
related by the fact that what the sum of
the squares to be on the circle is equal
to one we could even graph sine T
without any problem at all
namely we observe that when T is zero
sine T is zero notice that as we go
along the circle the sine increases up
until we get to PI over two at which it
peaks at one then decreases at pi back
down to zero and if that's giving you
trouble to follow let's simply come back
to our diagram to make sure that we
understand this in other words all we're
saying is as T gets longer its
y-coordinate increases from zero to a
maximum of one when the particle is over
here then as T goes from PI over 2 to PI
the white the length of the y coordinate
decreases till it again becomes zero and
again without making much more ado over
this we get the usual curve that we
associate with the sine function even
when we thought of it as a trigonometric
a traditional trigonometric problem but
the major point that I want you to see
right now is and we won't worry about
why I want to do this I can define the
trigonometric functions in such a way
that their domains are real numbers
rather than angles and in fact this is
the main reason why people invented the
notion of Radian measure let me see if I
can't make that a little bit clearer
once and for all
you see the question is this let's
suppose I'm talking
oh let me give some letters over here
we'll put a Q over here let's talk about
angle Q OS that's a right angle it's a
quarter of a rotation of this circle now
the question that I have in mind is if
something is a quarter of a rotation why
do you need two different ways of saying
that why do we have to say it's ninety
degrees or PI over two radians and bring
in a new measure when we already have
another way of measuring circles angles
of circles the idea is something like
this let's again mimic the idea of
taking the length T and laying it off
along the circle like this now here's
the idea remember the radius of this
circle is one so notice that PR in other
words this y-coordinate is what we
called by definition the sine of T in
other words just above we said that sine
T was the length r2p
in that direction now the point is I
said disregard traditional trigonometry
but we can't really disregard it it
exists for the person who's had four
additional trigonometry how would he
tend to look at this length divided by
this length he would think of that as
being what its side opposite over
hypotenuse that also should just sign
and the sign of what well the sine of
what angle this is now the thing is this
somehow or other to avoid ambiguity if
we could have called whatever measure
this angle was measured in terms of if
we could have called that unity then
notice that the sine of the angle T
would have been numerically the same as
the sine of the number T and again if
this seems like a hard point to
understand we explore this in great
detail in our notes but the idea is this
you see somehow or other if sine T is
going to have two different meanings we
would like to make sure that we pick the
kind of a unit where it makes no
difference whether
thinking of T is being a number or
thinking of T as being a length for
example suppose I now invent the word
Radian to mean the following an angle is
set to have T radians if when made the
central angle of a unit circle a circle
whose radius is one it subtends an an
arc whose length is T units of length C
in other words I will define the measure
called radians so that angle of T
radians intercepts the length T over
here in that way sine T is unambiguous
whether you're talking about an angle or
a length for example when I say the sine
of PI over 2 radians what do I mean I
mean the angle which the sine of the
angle which intercepts a length an arc
PI over 2 units long well see PI over 2
is this length I'm now talking about
this angle here and the sign therefore
of PI over 2 radians in terms of
classical trigonometry is 1 but that's
also what the sign of a number pi over 2
was but this explains the convention
that one says when one uses radians you
can leave the label off always saying is
that if we had used degrees there would
have been an ambiguity certainly the
sine of 3 degrees the sine of 3 degrees
is not the same as the sine of 3 you see
3 degrees is a rather small angle but 3
is a rather great length when you're
talking about the arc of the unit circle
here remember half the circle is PI
units long so 3 would be just about this
long in other words notice that 3
radians and 3 degrees are entirely
different things but the beauty is what
that if we agree to use Radian measure
then we have no ambiguity when we talk
about the sign the sign of the number T
will equal the sine of the angle T
radians the cosine of a number T will
equal the cosine of the angle T radians
in a certain sense it was analogous to
when we talked about the derivative
dy/dx then wanted to define
differentials dy and DX separately so
that dy / DX would be the same as dy DX
that we wanted to avoid any ambiguity
where the same symbol could be
interpreted in two different ways
to give two different answers by the way
again there is nothing sacred about our
choice of why we picked circular
functions we could have picked
hyperbolic functions namely why couldn't
we have started say with one branch of
the hyperbola x squared minus y squared
equals one given a length T why couldn't
we have measured T off along the
hyperbola say this way of T is positive
the other way if T is negative and then
what we could have done was dropped a
perpendicular again and we could have
defined what the y-coordinate
to be the hyperbolic but we couldn't
call a cosine anymore because it would
be confused with the circular functions
we could have invented the name as we
later will called the hyperbolic cosine
I won't go into any more detail on this
see this is an abbreviation for
hyperbolic cosine meaning this what I'm
sorry I get this backwards called the
x-coordinate the hyperbolic cosine the
y-coordinate the hyperbolic sine you
don't have to know anything about
advanced mathematics to see this all I'm
saying is I could just as easily have
taken any geometric figure knocked off
lengths along it take taken the x
coordinates and the Y coordinates and
seen what relationships they obeyed you
see as such there is nothing sacred
about working on a circle not only that
but even after you agree to work on the
circle there are many other ways that
one could have done this for example
someone might have said look at when you
take this length call T why did you
elect to mock it off along the circle
why couldn't you have taken a radius
equal to t taken s as a center and swung
an arc
met the circle and call call this length
t you see instead of measuring along the
circle measure along the straight line
again you could have done this if you
wanted to why you would have wanted to
do this well you have the same right to
do this as I had to do mine what should
have to be a little bit careful for
example in this particular configuration
notice that if this is how you're going
to define your trigonometric function
your input your domain has to be
somewheres between 0 & 2 in other words
you cannot have a length longer than 2
because notice that the diameter of this
circle is only 2 and therefore if T were
greater than 2 when you swung an arc
from the point s it wouldn't meet the
circle at all
well that's no great handicap it's no
great disaster you still have the right
to make up whatever functions you want I
will try to make it clearer why we chose
these circular functions from a physical
point of view as we go along what I
thought I'd like to do now is having
motivated that we can invent the
trigonometric functions in terms of
numbers definitions along as a circle
and coupled with the fact that in Radian
measure you can have a very nice
identification between what's happening
pictorially and what's happening
analytically to show for example it in
terms of our subject call calculus that
we're pretty much home free once we
learn these basic ideas you see the
important point is that in a manner of
speaking we have finished differential
calculus we know what all the recipes
are we know what properties things have
so all of the rules that we learned will
apply to any particular type of function
that we're talking about for example but
suppose we define f of X to be sine X
and we want to find the derivative of
sine X notice that F prime of X
evaluated at any number X 1 has already
been defined for us it's the limit as
Delta X approaches 0 f of x1 plus Delta
X minus f of X 1 over Delta X this is
true for any function f in particular if
f of X is sine X all we get is what
that a derivative is the limit as Delta
X approaches zero sine of X 1 plus Delta
X minus sine of X 1 over Delta X now you
see on this particular score nobody can
fault us this is still the basic
definition all that happens
computationally is that if we're not
familiar with our new functions called
the trigonometric functions we might not
know how to express sine of X plus 1 x1
plus Delta X in a more convenient form
what do we mean by a more convenient
form well notice again as is always the
case when we take a derivative as Delta
X approaches zero a numerator becomes
sine X 1 minus sine X 1 which is zero
over zero and we're back to our familiar
tableau form of zero over zero
somehow or other we're going to have to
make a refinement on our numerator that
will allow us to get rid of a 0 over 0
form well to make a long story short if
we happen to know the addition formula
for the sine in other words sine x1 plus
Delta X is sine x1 cosine Delta X plus
sine Delta X cosine X 1 then we subtract
off sine X 1 and divide by Delta X and
then we factor and collect terms we see
what without any knowledge of calculus
at all but just what by our definition
of derivative just by our definition
coupled with properties of the
trigonometric functions we wind up with
the fact that f prime of x1 is this
particular limit now certainly our limit
theorems don't change the limit of a sum
is still going to be the sum of the
limits the limits of a the limit of a
product will still be the product of the
limits so all in all what we have to
sort of do is figure out what these
limits will be certainly as Delta X
approaches 0 this will stay cosine X 1
certainly this will stay sine X 1
because x1 is a fixed number that
doesn't depend on Delta X but notice
rather interestingly that both of my
expressions in parentheses happen to
take on that 0 over 0 form if we're not
careful namely if you replace Delta X by
0
sign zero is zero zero over zero is zero
and we ran into trouble here if we
replace Delta X by zero which of course
we can't do this is the same definition
of limit as we had before Delta X gets
arbitrarily close to zero but never is
allowed to get there well you see if
nothing else this motivates why we would
like to learn this particular type of
limit now is what we would like to know
is how do you the Delta X symbol here
isn't that important Delta X just stands
for any number notice that what we would
like to know is if you take the sine of
something over that same something and
take the limit as that same something
goes to zero
we would like to know what that becomes
in a similar way we would like to know
how to handle this quotient here because
notice that when Delta X is zero cosine
0 is 1 this is 1 minus 1 over 0 it's
another 0 over 0 form so the problem
that we're confronted with is that what
we would like to do is to figure out how
to handle the limit of sine T over T as
T approaches 0
now what's T here T is a number remember
that this is the big pitch I've been
making we're thinking of t is a number
if on the other hand you feel more
comfortable thinking in terms of
traditional trigonometry and let's face
it the more backgrounds you've had in
traditional trigonometry the more
comfortable you're going to feel using
it let's simply agree to do this then if
it bothers you to think of this as a
length divided by a length etc and that
this is a length or a number let's agree
that we will go back to angles but use
Radian measure why because if the angle
is measured in radians the sine of the
angle T radians is the same as the
number the sign of the number T well
again here's how this problem is tackled
what we do is we mark off the angle of T
radians remember that we have a unit
circle and what we very cleverly do is
we catch our wedge our circular wedge
between two right triangles again
without making a big issue over this
notice that this line
is sine T this length is cosine T so the
area of the small triangle is sine T
times cosine T over two C sine T times
cosine T over two now on the other hand
since that's caught in our wedge what is
the area of our wedge
well since the area of the entire circle
is PI C PI R squared and R is 1 since
the area of the entire circle is PI and
we're taking what T of the two PI's
there are two pi radians in a circle so
the sector of the circle that we have
it's t over 2 pi of the entire circle
and by the way this is done more
rigorously and carried out in detail in
the notes let me point out that if we
insisted on working with degrees instead
of T over 2 pi we just would have had t
over 360 because you see if we're
dealing with degrees the entire angular
measure of the circle is 360 degrees and
we would have had t over 360 but here
we've used the fact that we're dealing
with radians okay
and finally the bigger triangle which
includes the wedge has as its base once
that's the radius and since the tangent
is side opposite over side adjacent this
length is tangent T and so what we have
is what that sine T cosine T over 2 must
be less than this which in turn must be
less than this multiplying through by 2
and dividing through by sine T and by
the way this hinges on the fact that T
is positive again in our notes we treat
the case where T is negative to arrive
at the same result
remembering that tan T is sine T over
cosine T we wind up with this result and
now observing that as T approaches 0 as
T approaches 0 this approaches 1 this
also approaches 1 and T over sine T is
caught between these two we get at the
limit of T over sine T as T approaches 0
is 1 now of course
this limit is one the limit of the
reciprocal of this will will be the
reciprocal of this but what's very nice
about the number one is there's equal to
its own reciprocal in other words what
we've now shown is that the limit of
sine T over T as T approaches zero is
one data as I said before is done in the
text we do it not notes but the thing
that I hope this motivates is why we
want to do this in the first place
notice that this was a limit that we had
to compute if we wanted to compute the
derivative of the sine see now the next
thing was how do we handle 1 minus
cosine T over T as T approaches zero
again leaving the details to you to
sketch in as you see fit let me point
out simply what the mathematics involved
here is you see what we can handle is
sine T over T that means that what we
would like to do is whenever we're given
an alien form we would somehow or other
like to figure some way of factoring a
sine T over T out of this thing when you
look at 1 minus cosine T the identity
sine squared equals 1 minus cosine
squared T should suggest itself now how
do you get from 1 minus cosine T to 1
minus cosine squared T you have to
multiply by 1 plus cosine T and if you
multiplied by 1 plus cosine T upstairs
you must multiply by 1 plus cosine T
downstairs by the way the only time you
can't multiply by something is one of
the is one of the thing is 0 you can't
put that into the denominator notice
that the cosine T is not 0 in a
neighborhood of T equals 0 C cosine T
behaves like 1 when T is near to 0 so
this is a permissible step in this
particular problem the point is we now
factor 1 minus cosine squared T as sine
T times sine T that sine squared T we
break up our t times 1 plus cosine T
this way now we know that the limit of a
product is the product of the limits
this we already know goes to 1 and as T
approaches zero from our previous limit
were
like notice here the limit of a quotient
is the quotient of the limits the
numerator goes to zero the denominator
goes to two because as T approaches zero
cosine 0 is 1 at any rate that's 0 over
2 which is 0 and so this limit is 0 now
at the risk of giving you a slight
headache as I take the port down here
let me just review what it was that we
did you see notice that without any
knowledge of these limits at all we were
able to show that whatever the
derivative of sine X was it was this
particular thing here now what we've
done is we've shown that this is 1 and
we've shown that this is zero and using
our limit theorems what we now see is
what that if f of X is sine X F prime of
X is cosine X let me just write that
down over here that if y equals sine X
dy/dx is cosine X and again notice how
much of the calculus involved here was
nothing new it goes back to the
so-called baby chapter that nobody likes
where we go back to epsilon deltas
you see derivatives by Delta X etc see
those recipes always remain the same
what happens is as you invent new
functions you need a different degree of
computational sophistication to find the
desired limits by the way once you get
over these hurdles everything again
starts to go smoothly as before for
example our chain rule suppose we have
now that y equal sine u where you with
some differentiable function of X and we
now want to find dy/dx well you see the
point is that we know that the
derivative of sine U with respect to u
would be cosine u what we want is the
rule of sine u with respect to X and we
motivate the chain rule the same way as
we did before it happens to be that
we're dealing with the specific value
called sine
in any old function how would you
differentiate F of U with respect to X
if you knew how to differentiate F of U
with respect to U and the answer is you
would just differentiate with respect to
U and multiply that by a derivative of U
with respect to X in other words we get
the result what that since dy du u is
cosine u we get that the derivative of
sine U with respect to X is cosine U
times du u DX by the way one rather nice
application of this is that gives us a
very quick way of getting the derivative
of cosine X after all our basic identity
is that cosine X is sine PI over 2 minus
X again a number or an angle either way
as long as the measurement is in radians
it makes no difference whether you think
of this as being an angle or being a
number the answer will be the same the
idea is this to take the derivative of
cosine X with respect to X all I have to
differentiate is sine PI over 2 minus X
with respect to X but I know how to do
that namely the derivative of sine PI
over 2 minus X is cosine PI over 2 minus
X and by the chain rule times the
derivative of this with respect to X
well PI over 2 is a constant the
derivative of minus X is minus 1 and
then remembering that the cosine of PI
over 2 minus X is sine X I now have the
result that the derivative of the cosine
is minus the sine and again I can do all
sorts of things this way if I want the
derivative of the tangent I can write
tangent as sine over cosine use the
quotient rule
you see as soon as I make one break
through all of the previous body of
calculus comes to my rescue so to speak
by the way what I'd like to do now is
point out why from the physical point of
view we like circular functions to be
independent of angles and the like with
the results that we've derived so far
it's rather easy to derive one more
result namely let's assume that a
particle is moving along the x axis I'm
going to start with the answer sort of
and we're
backwards according to the rule X equals
sine K T where T is time and K is a
constant then it's speed DX DT is what
is the derivative of sine KT which is
cosine KT times the derivative of what's
inside with respect to T in other words
it's K cosine KT the second derivative
of X with respect to T namely the
acceleration is what how do you
differentiate the cosine the derivative
of the cosine is minus the sine by the
chain rule I must multiply by the
derivative of KT with respect to T which
gives me another factor of T over here
remembering that x equals sine KT X
equals sine KT I arrive at this
particular so-called differential
equation and what does this say it says
add e to X DT squared the acceleration
is proportional to the displacement the
distance traveled but in the opposite
direction you see K squared can't be
negative so minus K squared can't be
positive this says what the acceleration
is proportional to the displacement but
in the opposite direction does that
problem require any knowledge of angles
to solve notice that this is a perfectly
good physical problem it's known as
simple harmonic motion and all I'm
trying to have you see is that by
inventing the circular functions in the
proper way not only can we do their
calculus but even more importantly if we
reverse these steps for example we can
show that to solve the physical problem
of simple harmonic motion we have to
know the so-called circular
trigonometric functions and this is a
far cry you see from using trigonometry
in the sense that the surveyor uses
trigonometry is this ties up with my
initial hang-up what I was telling you
about at the beginning of the program by
the way in closing I should also make
reference to something that we pointed
out in our last lecture namely inverse
differentiation keep in mind also that
as you read the calculus of the
trigonometric functions that the fact
that we know that
of sine u with respect to U is cosine u
gives us with a switch in emphasis the
result that the integral cosine u du u
is sine u plus a constant and in the
similar way since the derivative of
cosine is minus a sine the integral of
sine u with respect to U is minus cosine
u plus a constant
be careful notice how the signs can
screw you up namely there in the
opposite sense when you're integrating
as when you were differentiating but
again these are the details which I
expect you can have come out in the wash
rather nicely we can continue on this
way from knowing how to differentiate
sine X to the nth power namely it's n n
minus 1 x times the derivative of sine X
which is cosine X we don't want this in
here
that's a differential form without going
into any detail here notice that a
modification of this shows us that if we
differentiate this we wind up with this
we could now take the time if this were
the proper place to develop all sorts of
derivative formulas and integral
formulas as you study your study guide
you will notice that the lesson after
this is concerned with the calculus of
the circular functions my feeling is is
that with this as background a very good
review of the previous part of the
course will be to see how much of this
you can apply on your own to these new
functions called the circular functions
next time we will talk as you may be
able to guess about the inverse circular
functions and why they're important but
until next time goodbye
funding for the publication of this
video was provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate